welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i'm the
host of the show but
every now and then i invite on someone
to be my temporary guest co-host and
this week i invited greg knuckles he
graciously accepted so
i'd like to welcome greg to the show
thanks for joining me thanks for having
me on it is absolutely an honor
uh how are you doing today doing well
how are you i'm doing great um but i
want to dive right into the show we got
called out on the internet and uh as
much as i love to be defensive
uh the person calling us out had a point
we
made a very explicit commitment to
shorter episodes and last week
we ended up at like an hour 30 uh just
steadily creeping back to like two two
and a half hours so we are gonna do this
one in about an hour that is my
commitment but
before we get into the content um if you
like the show and you feel inclined to
support it there are many ways to do it
you could like rate and subscribe
wherever you happen to get podcasts you
could go to
bulksupplements.com and you could use
our discount code sbs pod sbs pod
that'll get you a five percent discount
off of your entire order at
bulksupplements.com you could subscribe
to the mass research review that's a
monthly research review greg and i are
both co-authors and we review the newest
uh
scientific papers that come out related
to exercise and nutrition and we do it
in a very practical way that tells you
not just what the studies mean but how
to use them and how to apply them in
your training or the training of your
clients and finally you could support
the show by subscribing to macro factor
that's the diet app that greg and i uh
co-developed along with a very talented
team of developers
and we do have a free trial so you can
try out the app see if you love it we
think you might uh and if you like it
you can
keep using it and stay subscribed so uh
moving on here i'm gonna start us off
with a research review segment about
fish oil which is a fan favorite topic
fish oil always gets attention
whether you're talking about fitness and
performance and body composition or just
talking about health in general you can
find a lot of articles about fish oil
some make
more exciting claims than others
and
so when it comes to this segment i want
to talk about fish oil specifically for
recovery and body composition purposes
i'm not going to talk about
the relationship between fish oil and
general health that has been done like i
said many many many times
in some particular for some particular
outcomes uh the utility seems clear for
other outcomes it's not quite as clear
and people like to argue quite a bit but
in general there are a lot of studies
looking at fish oil for a variety of
different health and wellness related
outcomes and when i say fish oil just
for context uh i'm just talking about
combined epa and dha supplementation or
supplementation with one or the other
so i could very i could just as well be
talking about algae oil rather than fish
oil or specifically an epa or a dha
supplement so
epa and dha are these two fatty acids
that um
are present in high quantities in fish
oil and they really are the active
ingredients so to speak in fish oil so
epa and dha
there are some difference between
differences between them if you are
focused on more health related outcomes
right now the evidence seems to indicate
that epa is probably more more helpful
when it comes to cardiovascular risk
reduction dha probably more applicable
when it comes to brain related outcomes
but there is definitely some overlap and
there are areas in which the two of them
do have some complementary effects but i
want to focus on recovery and body
composition and
what you might be wondering why even
bother like why would you look into the
effects of fish oil on body composition
and recovery when it comes to recovery
there is mechanistic evidence suggesting
that epa and dha both have
anti-inflammatory effects so the idea is
perhaps they might reduce some of the
inflammatory responses to arduous
training maybe they enhance recovery to
some extent
um there's also
uh you know there's some mechanistic
evidence suggesting that
uh enrichment of epa and dha
within muscle tissue itself could
enhance rates of muscle protein
synthesis
and decrease the expression of factors
that regulate muscle protein breakdown
so uh perhaps there's some inflammation
stuff that might help out with recovery
perhaps by consuming epa and dha we'll
incorporate that into our muscle tissue
and maybe that'll alter anabolic and
catabolic processes and promote uh the
accretion of new muscle proteins
and there's also some mechanistic
evidence suggesting that perhaps
fish oil could potentially alter fat
oxidation and energy expenditure so
maybe it could help when it comes to
burning some fat mass and losing fat
mass over time so there are some
mechanistic links here but as we know
we've seen this with just about every
supplement that's ever gotten popular
even the ones that don't pan out will
see some kind of plausible mechanism and
say oh well let's figure out if it
actually works in the real world
in applied studies that replicate how we
actually would want to use them
so
if you are a subscriber to mass you
might recall i actually reviewed a study
by van dusseldorp and colleagues
and
what they found was that after seven and
a half weeks of supplementing with
either two four or six grams per day of
fish oil
what they found was the group consuming
six grams of fish oil per day
generally had more favorable recovery
outcomes than the other groups when it
comes to vertical jump soreness and
blood biomarkers of muscle damage and i
believe what they did was they looked at
all these performance indices after a
pretty tough squat workout
if memory serves um
and so
at face value you'd say okay compared to
placebo 2 grams or 4 grams a day it
looks like this six grams per day of
fish oil is kind of the right dose like
you talked about in a recent episode for
a lot of supplements we don't have good
dose response uh relationships figured
out we haven't really done these types
of studies
so at the surface level you'd say great
so fish oil helps with recovery but it's
got to be you know up in that
over four gram a day dosing range
however
it's not fair to suggest that there was
like this perfect linear dose response
relationship because uh the differences
between zero two and four grams a day
were not very clear and not very
consistent it's not like two grams had a
small effect and four had a moderate
effect and then six grams had a large
effect it wasn't like that
and when you compare to other literature
in the area uh this kind of potential
threshold of dosing like that could be a
dose response effect if you say there's
basically no effect and then some kind
of threshold that's six and above and
you know that's it's not a linear dose
response pattern but it's still you know
the dose influences the magnitude of the
response
but when you compare to other studies
that kind of
threshold of over four grams doesn't
really seem to pan out the findings in
this area were generally pretty mixed
and the dosage did not seem to be the
thing that was really predicting which
studies fish oil was helpful for
recovery in which studies it was not now
there was a newer study by visconti and
colleagues in 2021
and
they very directly were kind of
replicating certain aspects of this van
duseldorf study it wasn't a perfect
like identical replication attempt but
what they did was they brought in young
resistance trained males
and they had them take one of three
doses zero grams per day six grams per
day or eight grams per day so it's kind
of saying okay let's take this idea that
six grams is kind of the the minimum to
get a significant effect let's look a
little higher as well but also include a
zero gram per day placebo group
and so what they found they they used a
very similar um protocol where they did
a very arduous squat
workout with some split uh some
split jump squats included as well just
trying to get some muscle damage going
basically yeah and then they looked at
uh recovery in terms of vertical jump
height soreness hip and knee range of
motion creatine kinase levels and also
squat reps to failure uh so the design
was extremely similar to the one by van
duseldorf and colleagues and that was a
very intentional decision but the
results were quite different um so the
the the exercise bout
did uh lead to changes in these outcomes
which was to be expected it was supposed
to induce soreness and give them some
kind of burden to recover from
but neither six nor eight grams per day
of fish oil significantly impacted any
of these recovery outcomes so
i was a bit stumped by this and trying
to make sense of this data
where you find sometimes these lower
doses are working sometimes the higher
doses are working there wasn't really a
clear pattern and so i looked into a
systematic review by anthony and
colleagues and it was really funny
because the authors state the initial
purpose
of this review was to investigate the
role of you know
long-chain omega-3 polyunsaturated fatty
acids so basically fish oil on eccentric
exercise-induced uh
soreness and inflammation so
uh they were talking about epa and dha
pretty much
but the key word there is initial
because basically what happened was
they started getting acquainted with the
literature that was available
and then the systematic review took a a
pretty hard pivot
and they're like you know what we're
gonna kind of abandon that initial
purpose and now just kind of talk about
all the reasons that this research is
inconsistent and has a ton of
shortcomings like it was very difficult
for them to get to a point where they
could really make the conclusions they
wanted to make
and basically they were just saying here
are all the reasons why we can't make
the conclusions we're hoping to um so
when you look at this body of literature
you know risk of bias tends to be pretty
high some of the study quality
individually some of these studies are
relatively low quality using various
scoring systems
there's a lot of variability in the
exercise protocols that are being used
to
induce muscle damage
a lot of the studies fail to exclude
participants who are consuming a lot of
fish and a lot of epa and dha
they fail to exclude participants based
on high tissue concentrations of epa and
dha
so it generally speaking in these
studies it's hard to tell
whether or not the supplementation
protocol is actually taking people from
a position or from a status of low
tissue epa and dha to high tissue epa
and dha
there's just a lot of variability and
it's really hard to sort through this
literature so um
i would say you know if you look at the
metas
here
it's generally speaking it looks like
fish oil has the potential to help out
with uh recovery and soreness and things
like that in the short term
but
a lot of times i'm seeing people make
claims about body composition related to
fish oil um you know it's it's far from
uh
a clear outcome even with the recovery
stuff like i said it's very hit or miss
but you can find a meta-analysis um i
forget the name of the author but i will
link it in the show notes where
they they did a systematic review with
meta-analysis and they did find that
these omega-3 polyunsaturated fatty
acids like epa and and dha they did
improve
recovery in terms of delayed onset
muscle soreness and muscle function
so there is evidence to suggest an acute
benefit for recovery um
but like i said i've seen some people
suggesting that we should not just be
using fish oil for recovery which is
kind of hit or miss but also that there
might be benefits for hypertrophy or fat
loss
i'm going to link these meta-analyses in
the show notes but one meta-analysis
looked at
the effects of fish oil
on hypertrophy
in people who are not doing exercise
training so untrained folks giving them
fish oil and what they found was five
out of the six studies that measured
changes in muscle volume and muscle mass
did show more favorable changes with uh
with fish oil so that's a really
positive thing and did get some people
excited but the same exact group did
another systematic review where they
looked at um and actually i don't know
if they did a meta-analysis in that
first one i i think i might have called
it a meta i think they might have just
done a systematic review but i'd have to
double check i i think you're right yeah
but they did another systematic review
where they said what about when you
throw exercise into the mix so is there
kind of either an additive or a
synergistic effect where we're still
seeing
that omega-3 fatty acids in this case
fish oil are actually promoting more
hypertrophy or improvements in muscle
strength or anything of that nature
when combined with exercise training and
so unfortunately what these two
systematic reviews showed was that
without training present uh omega-3
fatty acids did have some of these
positive effects on muscle protein uh
processes you know anabolic and
catabolic processes however when
training is involved
they did not notice improvements in
hypertrophy muscle strength or skeletal
muscle biomarkers of inflammation and
muscle damage they basically only found
positive effects for recovery in terms
of soreness and you know little muscle
function measurements like range of
motion uh muscle quality via ultra
ultrasound and things like that and then
finally
there was a meta-analysis looking at the
effects of fish oil on weight loss and
fish oil in that meta-analysis did not
have a significant effect on reducing
body weight or bmi
it was uh fairly underwhelming looking
at the results so they concluded that
current evidence cannot support an
anti-obesity role of omega-3 fatty acids
basically it just wasn't wasn't doing
much in terms of fat loss so
when it comes to fish oil um
i still think it's not a terrible idea
to have some epa and dha coming into
your diet
for a variety of reasons unrelated to
building muscle getting stronger losing
fat i think when you look at the various
roles of epa and dha in physiology
it's hard to view more epa and dha in
your system as a particularly negative
thing within within reasonable
boundaries so uh generally speaking
you'll see a lot of review papers
focused on general health and wellness
that say hey
try to get like 0.3 to 0.5 grams a day
of combined epa and dha that could come
from fish oil it could come from algae
oil you know whatever you prefer
it's still unclear from my perspective
if higher doses will lead to any
tangible benefits that relate to lifting
recovery hypertrophy fat loss anything
of that nature but i still think it's a
good idea to seek out some epa and dha
in your diet for completely unrelated
reasons so i'd say 0.3 to 0.5 grams per
day on average doesn't doesn't mean you
have to get that every day but over the
course of a week you know if you're
averaging that intake per day
that's probably a good place to be if
you want to go a little bit higher i
think it's pretty reasonable to go up to
like one
maybe even up to two grams a day two two
i think is kind of the highest end for
me where i'd say yeah that makes a lot
of sense
there are some select instances where
you might want to go higher but i
haven't really seen strong enough
evidence to convince me that more than
one or two grams a day of combined epa
and dha would really be
uh
an important thing to do or a tangibly
beneficial thing to do and the caveat
that i always like to point out here uh
if you are taking relatively high doses
of epa and dha
it can increase bleeding time so so like
if you were to you know have a wound uh
that bleeding might not stop quite as
quickly if you were taking high doses of
fish oil so like for instance if you
were going in for a surgery or something
like that you would absolutely want to
make sure that your medical team knows
that you've been taking epa and dha so
all of that is to say epa and dha are
still very interesting um
components of the diet i still think you
want to sink seek them out
but i don't think you want to seek them
out as a
potent anabolic
dietary ingredient
more research i'm sure will be done that
will clarify some of these unresolved
questions about promoting hypertrophy
and uh promoting acute recovery but for
now there's just not as much uh exciting
evidences as you'd like to believe
unfortunately yeah so that's one
perspective um
i i just wondering in your literature
search did you come across
a
i assume this is a systematic review uh
published on the biotest website about
about fish oil do they they keep
publishing these systematic reviews that
that you find and for some reason my
pubmed search is not catching yeah
so i think you need to look at a variety
of databases don't just be a normie who
stops at pubmed and google scholar uh
there's a great research database on
tnation uh which you can mostly find on
their sales pages
so let's let's just um
present an alternate case for
uh
omega-3s epa and dha
so they're saying that in fact uh fish
oil does boost metabolic rate and burn
more fat
and so
i think you may have been a little bit
off base there uh increases insulin
sensitivity supports lean mass and
muscle gains uh switches the body to
prefer fat burning over glycogen
and boosts cellular parentheses
mitochondrial energy consumption so
it seems like there's a lot of good
stuff going on you're saying uh 0.3 to
0.5 grams of eat of combined epa and dha
per day they're saying a little bit over
three grams um
so
you know those dosing recommendations
from your source of science
uh which i assume has a ton of conflicts
of interests are a little bit lower than
this source of science that i as far as
i can tell is uh completely devoid of
conflicts of interest
um
and yeah so i just learned omega-3 fatty
acids increase the heat of your cellular
furnaces known as mitochondria and
peroxisomes that in and here's some
innovation right here they're referring
to them as furnaces instead of the
powerhouse of the cell
so that's i think a new shift in
terminology
um
so yeah anyway
i would say that we're a pretty
open-minded podcast and in this like all
things i believe we should teach the
controversy um
yeah just just wanted to make sure that
your
uh skeptical
interpretation of this literature wasn't
the only thing presented because there
there is
a variety of viewpoints uh that
as with all things all are equally valid
yeah because i did look up the
the one on fat loss was by do and
colleagues that was a meta analysis and
i control i did control f they didn't
even mention furnaces in the entire
paper that's a major oversight yeah um
and by the way just to give credit uh
the other two that i mentioned about uh
hypertrophy and strength outcomes those
were systematic reviews with without a
meta analysis component both of them
were written by lopez
say joanne
and colleagues i'm certain i
mispronounced that but like i said the
links will be in the show notes
so greg do you want to do a research
review you want to do q a what are you
thinking yeah so my my research review
uh more than anything is just a brief
research shout out also just just a note
to be clear for our listeners who don't
get sarcasm uh
i'm not recommending biotest sales pages
as a valid form of
a valid place for research
interpretation just to be clear
interesting uh so anyway um
yeah so i i want to give a bit of a
shout out without going into too much
depth
about a recent systematic review that
was published looking at the research on
sports psychology
so
sports psych is a field
that i think most coaches should at
least be
aware of and keep up to some degree i
will admit that it's not
an area where i tend to go super super
in depth um but it is and part of that
just relates to the fact that there's
been so much research and i feel like
i would need to
do a tremendous amount of reading to
kind of get caught up on on where the
current state of the of the literature
is and there's just so much stuff being
published
you kind of have to pick your spots and
kind of know
um
just how many different bodies of
literature you as an individual can
reasonably keep up with and for me
sports psych something i think is cool
but not something that i want to
invest the time into being like super
super caught up on
um
so that's part of the reason that i'm
not going to go super in depth here but
as i mentioned a systematic review was
published that i think is worth
mentioning because if you dear listener
are very interested in sports psychology
this is a tremendous resource for
um
exploring and discovering more of the
literature and just kind of a jumping
off point for your own reading and
learning so the title of this systematic
review was sports psychology and
performance meta-analyses
colon a systematic review of the
literature by lock balm and colleagues
published in plos
uh and so it's exactly what it sounds
like they
it was a systematic review of
meta-analyses so not a systematic review
and meta-analysis a systematic review of
meta-analyses but basically they had a
set of of predetermined search criteria
defined all of the meta-analyses in
sport psychology
investigating the
either relationship between various
psychological variables and
sport or exercise performance or the
impact of various sport psychology
interventions
on uh on performance
and
so basically what they found is that
overall the field of sports psychology
seems to be on pretty strong evidentiary
grounds so they identified 30 various
meta-analyses in sport psychology
and
the psychological characteristics or
interventions that were that have been
theorized to either improve performance
or be associated with higher performance
do in fact tend to be um when you kind
of pool all of those things that are
supposed to have positive effects
together all of the effect estimates
from all of the various meta-analyses
you do see a mean positive effect a d
value of about 0.5 which is typically
interpreted as a medium-sized positive
effect and all of the things that are
that have been theorized to
either be correlated with negative
performance or to cause negative
performance
the mean effect for those things is a
small negative effect a d of negative
0.21 so overall seems like the field
basically knows what it's doing
basically knows what it's talking about
the things that are supposed to work
seem to work the things that are
supposed to have negative effects do
seem to have negative effects
so overall that's very positive uh it's
worth noting that
so if you pull up this study which
everyone should be able to do plos is an
open access journal so everyone can
access this uh if you pull up the study
and look at figure two
it just plots all of the effect
estimates from all of these systematic
or all of these meta-analyses um
and just pulling a couple out the
largest positive effect was for
mindfulness interventions which
surprised me a little bit honestly
and the largest negative effect was for
total mood disturbances so that's coming
from the profile of mood states
questionnaire basically if someone says
i'm angry i'm confused i have low vigor
blah blah blah just like all of these
various things basically saying like
yeah my vibes are very bad tends to be
associated with poor performance uh one
thing i'll note is when you pull up this
study and check it out i wouldn't
necessarily interpret
all of the effect estimates in that
figure 2
as directly applicable apples to apples
comparisons just because
all of these various meta-analyses
included in the systematic review
included different studies with
different research techniques etc etc
but you know it will give you
kind of a rough idea of what sorts of
characteristics or interventions seem to
be
more beneficial and which ones seem to
have a larger deleterious effect on
performance
to just kind of get your feet under you
and also
it's worth noting and i think a lot of
the value of the systematic review
comes from the authors identifying
weaknesses both in the meta-analyses
that current currently exist in sport
psychology and also within the
underlying literature that kind of go
that went into those meta-analyses
they they identified
quite a few current weaknesses in the
literature but a few of the more notable
ones were
a lot of the meta-analyses were
meta-analyses of cross-sectional studies
which can't necessarily be used to imply
causation
um
so i think 30 meta-analyses went into
this systematic review and 18 of the 30
were just looking at cross-sectional
research
of the studies that actually used
interventions
a lot of them
a lot of them used control groups which
is good but they didn't use control
groups that would have been adequate for
controlling for expectancy effects so
basically
if you
you know like let's say you have a
mental imagery um
[Music]
a mental imagery um
what's the word i'm looking for
intervention that's the word i'm looking
for so you have a mental imagery
intervention and you have two groups and
one of them you say hey we're going to
test your performance then you're going
to do all of this mental imagery
training then we're going to test your
performance again and then you have a
control group where you say hey we're
going to test your performance and then
two weeks later you're going to come
into the lab and we're going to test
your performance again
so you know on the surface that looks
like good intervention group good
control group you're good to go
but a drawback there
is basically that humans aren't stupid
like human research subjects know if
they're in the control group
and
if you have an intervention that
it's pretty clear to the subjects that
you're expecting it to improve
performance that's going to induce some
positive some positive expectancy
effects in the intervention group that
wouldn't necessarily be there in the
control group and so it's difficult to
know whether the intervention itself was
having positive
effects or if just the expectancy of a
positive effect from an intervention
that people think is going to work if
that's the actual thing uh driving the
positive effects
so they they identified that as a
relatively consistent weakness in a lot
of the studies on the actual
intervention meta-analyses
and also a lot of the
a lot of the interventions and a lot of
the correlates that are associated with
performance or
are supposed to improve performance a
lot of them lack clearly proposed
underlying mechanisms to explain
why they're effective for increasing or
decreasing performance so ultimately if
you're
using kind of a theory-based science
paradigm like it's good to know that
something works but it's also
good to know why it works uh because if
you have that underlying mechanism in
place and you can kind of build upon
that to
you know understand a subject deeper
that one
gives you an indication that the actual
outcomes you're finding are legitimate
because they're kind of underpinned by a
well-understood mechanism and two it
just helps you extend the research
further like if there's
a well understood mechanism and one sort
of intervention
based on that mechanism tends to improve
performance there might be other
possible mechanisms based on that or
other possible interventions based on
that same mechanism that might also
improve performance which you can then
test if you do understand that mechanism
but a lot of this research
isn't necessarily mechanistically based
it's it's more just like
hey here's this thing that we think will
improve performance let's test it oh
cool it does improve performance let's
move on
so this is a field where
um kind of
deeper research into underlying
mechanisms might pay pretty big
dividends so those were some of the
drawbacks that were noted uh in this
systematic review of meta-analyses
um
and so like i said i mostly just wanted
to very very briefly talk about this
because if you are really into sports
psychology or if you would like to get
into sports psychology and just
really dive into this body of literature
this paper would be a really really good
one to start with oftentimes when we
talk about
when we talk about on this podcast
how to go about
not just reading and interpreting a
single study but sinking your teeth into
a body of literature one of the things
we consistently recommend is trying to
find a recent systematic review and
meta-analysis or meta-analysis uh
dealing with the subject you're
interested in learning about both to get
a broad overview of the literature as it
stands today but then two like those
review papers are going to cite all of
the individual studies that are kind of
underpinning their findings and analysis
and so if you really want to get into it
you know you you can just
you can just mind the citations and then
dig into all of the original research
that underpins those review papers so
since this is
functionally a review of reviews the
vast vast majority of individual studies
within sport psychology
are going to be cited within the
systematic reviews and meta-analyses
that
are cited in this systematic review so
it's basically just a jumping off point
that will branch you towards
just about all of the sports psych
literature that you could ever want to
read
if this is a subject that you want to
dive into more deeply so
independent of its uh
of its kind of
acute utility as a standalone paper uh
it's also
it has a ton of utility just as a
jumping off point to learn more about
the field
that's awesome man i think uh all of our
listeners on the road to enlightenment
are going to be really happy to hear
that largest effect size coming from
mindfulness interventions no no need to
investigate that deeper no just take it
at face value you're good to go
absolutely um cool so i want to move on
to the q a segment here and i've got one
question i'm going to answer i know
you've got at least a couple you want to
get to
um
mine uh i'm gonna answer something
briefly um
i absolutely could have made a very long
um
segment out of this but i'm gonna paint
with a broad brush so i'm acknowledging
that on the front end i am very
concisely summarizing big topics here so
if you hear the way that i discuss one
of these theories and you say eric
you're an idiot that doesn't capture
every nuance of the theory
i'm admitting to that on the front end
but i am going to provide a resource
that does not paint with a broad brush
i'm going to link to a paper that gives
some really exceptional
definitions and explanations of these
topics but i had a question in the
stronger by science facebook group by
matthias
and he asked if i could address or
summarize
the topic of body fat set points in the
next uh stronger by science podcast
episode uh so what i'd like to do is
refer readers to a paper by john
speakman and colleagues i've mentioned
his work many times before on the
podcast he's done some really excellent
work in metabolism the paper is called
set points settling points and some
alternative models and then there's a
bunch of stuff after the colon so i'll
link to that paper but
the short version the reason somebody
wanted me to
kind of expand upon this is someone
asked in the facebook group about body
fat set points and i mentioned that i
think there are alternative models that
do a better job of explaining
how body weight is uh
uh i guess managed over time how body
weight fluctuates within certain
constraints over time um and so i i
wanted to point out a few things that
are covered within this paper um
there is
first the kind of classical set point
theory
and the set point theory
oversimplifying pretty aggressively here
is basically the idea
that
our body has a particular body fat level
that it likes to defend and so
theoretically when we get too far from
that set point there is
some degree of uh feedback within the
body some degree of signaling cascades
that send the message hey you're getting
away from where we want to be in terms
of body fat and therefore theoretically
you know if your body was wired to
protect
a particular
point or if we're being generous a range
of body fat then once you start getting
lower than that range uh you know you
would theoretically either reduce energy
expenditure or increase energy intake
and get back into that range there would
be
physiological factors nudging you back
up toward that range and conversely if
you started gaining weight to the point
that you were getting
higher than that range theoretically
you'd have reduced appetite or or other
feedback systems to kind of push you
back down so that's the idea and they
kind of lay out all the evidence for and
against it but the very simplified point
that they're trying to make here
is that
first of all you know
bmi levels obesity rates overweight
prevalence has gone up quite a bit since
the 1980s and there's no clear evidence
why set points at a population level
would kind of drift upward over the last
40 something years
and then when we look at other
correlates with weight gain or fat gain
one of the things they said in the paper
as a quote was
if the if the body fat set point changes
in response to our social class marital
marital status or whether or not we
watch television then it's not really a
set point you know so
the issue that they'd have with the
setpoint theory is that it is
excessively dependent on
biology and physiology and doesn't
really leave enough room for other
factors that influence body weight so it
doesn't acknowledge a lot of the
psychological behavioral environmental
factors
then they talk about the settling point
model which is based on the idea that
there's kind of passive feedback between
the size of your body and certain
aspects of energy expenditure but
basically
in the paper they they have an analogy
about like a reservoir of water um and
they actually have like a literal
picture of a of a reservoir and the idea
is you know energy intake goes up it's
higher than energy expenditure that
reservoir fills up with water or in
other words we start gaining fat mass
but at a certain point
that reservoir basically starts to
overflow
and at a certain point as as body fat
levels go up generally speaking we will
run into some constraint at the higher
end because our body gets bigger our
energy expenditure goes up but what they
are basically uh
showing within this kind of analogy is
that we've got this kind of
energy intake component of water flowing
into the reservoir and we've got this
energy expenditure component of water
flowing out of the reservoir
and the rate of outflow is linked to the
overall volume of the reservoir
so there's a nice little analogy that
shows how the model works but
in a way their issue with uh and i think
they make a very compelling uh case here
the issue with the settling point theory
is it doesn't leave enough room for some
of the physiological constraints so it's
kind of an over correction that does a
lot to explain how different
environmental factors can um
influence the defense of certain body
weight ranges and body weight changes
over time but it is a bit of an over
correction in the sense that it
fixes a lot of the problems with the
setpoint theory but
fails to address some of the good
aspects of the setpoint theory
so in this paper they present two other
models that in my opinion are
more compatible with both the
mechanistic evidence and the population
level trends that we see over time so
the first one is the general model of
intake regulation
and you can open the paper to kind of
see how they diagram everything but the
basic idea is that there are both
compensated and uncompensated factors
that influence energy intake
and on the compensated side of things
there is some degree of feedback where
you know compensated factors
physiological factors related to body
weight regulation are influencing intake
but intake is also having a feedback
loop that influences those compensated
factors so those things are to some
degree operating in a feedback loop but
the uncompensated factors we could talk
about um these are kind of
non-physiological things like our
environment you know our our habits
related to food intake
these things do not operate in a clear
feedback loop the way that you know we
might
you know gain some some weight and
energy expenditure goes up and leptin
levels goes up and appetite goes down
there are two different sides of this
coin and there are compensated
biological feedback loops that are
keeping things within certain ranges but
those uncompensated factors can still
override some of that and push us to
higher body fat levels than we would
otherwise be defending
in my opinion the most interesting model
and again i don't want to go too long
with this segment is
the uh the dual intervention point model
and it also
um
acknowledges the fact that there are
compensated and uncompensated or
physiological and non-physiological
factors that dictate body weight
regulation but it basically makes the
argument that we've got an upper
intervention point and a lower
intervention point and we can think of
this as kind of the upper and lower body
weight range that we feel really
comfortable in
and our behaviors our eating environment
psychological aspects related to food
that will kind of dictate when we're
fluctuating toward the higher end of
that range or the lower end but then
once we get beyond a certain point some
of those physiological feedback loops
kick in and they really do constrain our
weight change beyond a certain level so
like for me personally i can easily bulk
up to about 185 if i try to bulk up two
higher than like to too much above like
195
my appetite just like shuts down um i
can cut down to
160 pretty easily once i start getting
155 150 my hunger's through the roof my
energy expenditure tanks um so this kind
of resonates with me because i know
my body weight can kind of drift around
between
you know 160 and 180 something like that
i
forget what numbers i i threw out
earlier but that's kind of the general
range where
you know just kind of
environmental changes behavioral changes
my weight will float around in there but
it's pretty clear when you start to bump
into your upper and lower intervention
points and you're starting to get
pretty significant feedback from your
body that's like yeah dude
you're heavier than you like to be your
appetite is just cut or you know you
start getting super low and it's like
hey you you really ought to eat more
like hungers through the roof energy
expenditures down so i personally think
that the dual intervention point model
is a very um
a very solid way to conceptualize body
weight regulation and i would highly
encourage people to check that out for
more information but if you ever see me
in a facebook group saying yeah i'm not
really into body fat set points as a
comprehensive theory
it's because i think this dual
intervention theory makes a lot more
sense
okay so kicking to you uh as many
questions as you'd like to answer we're
about 44 minutes into the episode give
or take the floor is yours
oh yeah easy peasy i've got i've got
three questions and uh
i will try to be as quick as possible
i'll admit i went longer than i planned
with both of mine so i i can't blame you
if you go a little a little over yeah
it's fine we'll we'll see what happens
so um we did address uh one of the
questions from reddit in the last
episode so i have one more reddit
question to address here from b health
performance what is the proposed
mechanism for why working muscles at
longer muscle links produces more
hypertrophy
so this question is asking about
proposed mechanisms not
necessarily trying to litigate whether
longer ranges of motion or maybe long
muscle length partials are better just
assuming they are which there's a quite
a fair bit of evidence for what are some
potential mechanisms to
explain those findings so
there are a few
one is
just straight up classic tension and
mechanotransduct
so
muscular tension is one of the
initiators of
your local skeletal muscular hypertrophy
response
and
the reason tension is important is it
kicks off a process called
mechanotransduction
basically you have little proteins on uh
the cell membrane of your muscles called
your sarcolemma where
uh when when they feel
tension
like when there's tension between the
fiber itself and the surrounding
connective tissue that puts like
shearing force on those adhesive
adhesion proteins that are kind of
hooking your muscle fibers into the
connective tissue matrix and
when that shearing force is put on those
proteins at those adhesion points that
kicks off a big cellular signaling
cascade
that ultimately results in up
regulations in ribosome biogenesis and
muscle protein synthesis um
and so
the details of that relationship aren't
fully worked out so you know it's pretty
clear that a little tension will give
you some degree of hypertrophic response
more tension will tend to give you a
greater hypertrophic response
but it's hard to know whether you hit a
limit whether it's like a threshold type
system whether it's just purely linear
we don't know for sure
but if it's not if it's not a sort of
relationship where you do just hit a
limit then training at long muscle links
may be beneficial just via
increasing the total amount of tension
that is on a muscle and therefore
enhancing mechanotransduction
because when a muscle is stretched that
puts more direct tension on the
connective tissue within the muscle
itself
which could therefore increase the
shearing forces
between the muscle fibers and the
surrounding connective tissue matrix
therefore potentially greater
mechanotransduction greater hypertrophy
signaling so that's one possibility
another possibility is just muscle
deoxygenation so
there's some research uh a couple papers
out of japan the the ones coming to mind
for me uh the researchers are kubo and
tana moto um so they've been looking at
the impact of just muscle deoxygenation
on hypertrophy signaling
and there's some evidence suggesting
that kind of all else being equal if you
train pretty hard you push a set pretty
hard the greater levels of muscle
deoxygenation that you achieve at the
end of a set
might be predictive of the
magnitude of the hypertrophic response
you get and so when a muscle is under
stretch
that can
that can cut off uh blood flow from
veins and if you put push a set hard
enough it can cut off some arterial
blood flow as well um
i'm not
super sold on that so so a muscle under
stretch like that will or that can put
more occlusive
pressure on some of those blood vessels
i'm not a hundred percent sold on this
as the mechanism
or long muscle length training
specifically um
largely just because if you push a set
pretty hard um
this will likely occur anyways kind of
regardless of of how you're training um
and i think this would be more relevant
to long muscle length partials uh rather
than just kind of full range of motion
training versus partial range of motion
training and
since full range of motion training does
still seem to be better than short short
muscle length partial range of motion
training um
i don't think i don't think we can chalk
it all up to just muscle deoxy
deoxygenation but that that's one
potential contributor another one is uh
local autocrine and paracrine signaling
so i should have pulled this paper up
but i didn't um
but there there was one paper that i
believe was looking
at knee extensions with full range of
motion versus partial range of motion
training uh that looked specifically at
the
kind of local hormonal response so not
looking at
you know you just take a venous blood
draw and look at uh igf-1 and
testosterone levels kind of going all
through circulation but take a muscle
biopsy and see like what's actually
going on within the muscle itself
in terms of hormonal responses to
training it does seem like the local
hormonal responses may matter a bit more
than the systemic hormonal responses and
so there is one paper that
specifically looked at this with partial
versus full range of motion training
finding that if memory serves uh local
igf-1 levels within the quads were
higher
following full range of motion training
than partial range of motion training
so that could be
related to just like the total tension
and stretch mediated stuff
might be related to muscle deoxygenation
who's to say but
that could that could be one additional
factor that might be contributing uh and
then one final possibility that i
haven't seen floated all that much in
the literature but that i think might be
contributing
is maybe just exposing a region of a
muscle to tension that is not quite as
used to being put under high levels of
tension so one of the things we've
talked about on the podcast before
as it relates to range of motion and
hypertrophy
is that
you can kind of get a inhomogeneous
response throughout a muscle belly uh
when it comes to hypertrophy with
different training with different ranges
of motion so
basically if you're doing short muscle
length partials so
uh for example if you're doing
half squats or something like that
you're only going down to 90 degree knee
angle coming back up
versus full range of motion squatting
what
what you tend to see is that for
proximal parts of the muscle so if
you're looking at the quads the parts of
the quads that are closer to the hip you
tend to see pretty similar hypertrophy
with partial versus full range of motion
training
but for the middle of the muscle belly
and especially the distal parts of the
muscle belly so in the case of squats
closer to your knee that would be the
distal parts of the quads
when you're training at longer muscle
links you tend to have much greater
hypertrophy in the distal regions of the
muscle
than you would when you're doing short
muscle length partial range of motion
training um
the one possibility there
is just that the forces
that you're exposing the muscle to
aren't uniformly distributed when you're
doing stuff and basically the proximal
parts of a muscle are
uh the regions of the muscle that are
contributing more when you're kind of
not going through out all that much uh
joint range of motion and so you know
when you're just walking around you're
not going through a ton of knee flexion
uh
and maybe just like the proximal parts
of your quads are taking most of that
tension doing most of that work
and so just the distal parts of the
muscles are being exposed to less stress
throughout day-to-day life but then when
you do full range of motion training or
long muscle length partials
now you're redistributing more of the
stress to those distal portions of the
muscle
and therefore just putting more stress
on them causing a greater hypertrophy
response
so you know it could be none of the
other things i just mentioned and more
just that in day-to-day life the distal
regions of muscles are generally under
trained and by training at long muscle
links you expose them to tension when
you otherwise want into those
specifically distal regions of the
muscle and ultimately that results in
greater overall muscle growth but really
not much of a difference uh at the
proximal portions of the muscle so
uh those those are all possibilities uh
that could explain why training at long
muscle links tends to produce more
hypertrophy
moving on from the facebook group athena
d'eon
asks
would micro workouts be helpful for
muscle building at all for example
getting 100 reps of bicep curls a day by
doing 10 sets of 10 throughout the day
um
yeah i think this is very possible
um
so first just kind of reasoning by
analogy here
if you want to see
some of the best forearm development in
the world outside of
like professional arm wrestlers and
professional bodybuilders just look at
manual laborers who are
winging hammers lane bricks lane cinder
blocks most of them have
absurd forearm development even if
they're not doing any dedicated
resistance training just because they
are exposing those muscles to some
degree of loading some degree of stress
throughout the day um
so yeah i think like
just kind of looking around the real
world there is some conceptual evidence
for this idea
um
and also just kind of
further reasoning by analogy but now
talking about research a little bit more
we mentioned this on on the last podcast
episode uh if you're very sedentary and
just start exposing your lower body
musculature to
a tiny tiny little bit of stress you can
get a hypertrophy response from that so
if you go from being very sedentary to
just walking more
or doing some very light cardio that can
cause some hypertrophy just just from
doing stuff with those muscles that you
often aren't using a ton throughout the
day
and you know i could see that
potentially applying to
upper body muscles like in general
throughout the day you are using your
lower body muscles more than your upper
body muscles like your biceps aren't
super engaged in walking um
they're maintaining some level of
tension just to kind of hold your
shoulder in place but you know they you
generally aren't doing that much with
your biceps throughout the day
especially in relation to your lower
body muscles are you suggesting that
people start br bear crawling rather
than
walking on two legs that is
i mean that's one possibility uh but but
anyway so you know
i i could see
maybe just exposing your upper body
muscles to
more
consistent just even fairly slight
challenges throughout the day maybe
having some degree of positive effect
for hypertrophy
um
however one thing i will note just to be
very clear
the research looking at training
multiple times per day does not go up to
doing
10 sets spread into 10 small workouts
throughout the day uh the the highest
i've seen is three a days um and that
was a very very
low volume study by xiao i believe um
but yeah like
i'm not gonna claim that there's direct
research support for this i'm just
saying if if someone put a gun to my
head and said hey do you think this
could work i'd say yeah yeah like if if
i think there's a
better than 50 chance that it has a
positive effect rather than than a
negative effect in terms of
estimating how large that magnitude of
positive effect is i don't know who's to
say
um
one piece of practical advice i would
give though is if you want to give this
a shot
one uh reach out let me know how it goes
i'm very interested uh two
ease into it um
you know assuming you're not uh
presently doing a level of biceps
training volume that would equate to 100
reps per day like you're not you're not
currently doing 700 reps per day of
bicep training um
going from basically zero to 100
right from the jump
would be putting a lot more stress both
on the muscles but also in the soft
tissues than
uh your body is probably acclimated to
so that could set you up potentially for
overuse injuries so i would recommend if
you want to go this route ease into it
um
you know maybe just go with
one set of 10 every day if that's going
fine
maybe maybe jump to three sets
and then if that's going fine maybe jump
to five sets but just like slowly build
your way up to 10 sets or if you want to
go 10 sets from the jump maybe leave
five or six reps in reserve every set
and then slowly ramp up the difficulty
of those sets but basically don't go
from
not currently doing daily bicep training
to doing 10 very hard sets every day
that is probably not a great idea but
yeah just be smart about it ease into it
and uh if you give it a shot let me know
how it goes
good stuff we're at 59 minutes can you
do uh the next q a
relatively concisely yeah i think so
okay so uh the last one also from
facebook is from kim josephson uh
question is about junk volume and
session volume what are your thoughts on
a maximum number of sets per session for
a body part you've talked about if you a
theoretical limit to how much useful
volume could be in a session before in
mass
some of that discussion was based on the
barballio studies that have been
retracted
lately jeff nippert made a video on the
same subject generally looking at three
to six sets as a theoretical cap per
session
um
i watched jeff's video my
remembrance of it was that he said six
to eight sets is a starting point per
session uh but but regardless just
talking about this question conceptually
um you know basically what is the
highest per muscle
amount of productive volume that you can
do in a single session
i i do think that uh six to eight sets
is probably a pretty good starting point
um
so in jeff's video he cited an analysis
from wadeology uh james krieger's
website and research review which i
would strongly recommend it's very good
um
and yeah i think that that's a perfectly
reasonable starting point kind of based
on
averages from the research as it exists
today that seems to give you the vast
majority of the benefits that you can
receive for a single muscle from a
single training session and
you you might get either diminishing
returns or maybe even no further returns
from higher per session volumes than
that kind of on average
a couple of things i'll note though is
one this will likely depend on proximity
to failure so most of the research that
exists just has people training to
failure basically every set and so six
to eight sets to failure for a given
muscle group um you know
the six to eight set recommendation the
unstated assumption is six to eight sets
per failure to failure for a given
muscle group if you're leaving a few
reps in reserve the
per session
set volume recommendation would probably
be a bit higher than that it's hard to
say how much higher but you know i i
would use that not as kind of an optimal
range but as kind of a lower end range
if you're leaving more reps in reserve
and also the other thing i'll note is i
think that this varies more between
individuals than a lot of people assume
and or realize
there was a study by scarpelli that came
out in 2020 the title was muscle
hypertrophy response is affected by
previous resistance training volume in
trained individuals so basically what
they did in this study
is um
they used a within subject design and
they asked people hey what does your
training volume for quads look like
right now
and what they did for one group is they
assigned them a level of quad training
volume
that was basically in keeping with what
is typically prescribed for quad
training in the literature i think it
was like 20 to 22 sets per week
something like that um
so it was split into two sessions so it
was basically like 10 11 sets per day
and then for the other leg what they did
is they took the subjects reported
baseline training volume and then just
said okay for each one of you you're
just going to increase your baseline
training volume by twenty percent if
someone was only previously doing five
sets of quad training per week they'd be
doing six sets if someone was previously
doing
20 sets of quad training per week they'd
be doing 24 sets if someone was doing 40
sets of quad training per week they'd be
doing 48 sets um so they they just use
the subject's baseline as what they
built on
and what they found is that on average
the
individualized approach so increasing 20
over baseline
on average produced statistically
significantly more quad hypertrophy than
the one size fits all 22 sets per week
or 11 sets per session approach
and also when you dig into this paper
and look at the individual results there
were a lot of subjects who were doing
quite a bit more than
eight than six to eight sets per session
um
who were doing
like way more than what would be
assumed to be like optimal based on
uh kind of population level data or just
like the the
group level results from studies that
exist so basically the implication is
there were
quite a few people in this study who
were growing more
on way more than
uh 22 sets per week than they were on 22
sets per week suggesting that for those
individuals the optimal per session
volume was quite a bit higher than six
to eight sets per session
um
all of which is to say
you know
any sort of general recommendations like
this you need to you need to
contextualize them uh if you're training
to failure or very close to failure six
to eight sets per muscle group per week
or
six to eight sets per muscle group per
session probably a pretty decent
starting point
but you need to keep the details of the
sets in mind so if you're training quite
a bit further from failure it's probably
going to be higher on average and then
second remember all of these
recommendations are just averages to
start at to start your troubleshooting
for you uh the the per session optimal
volume per muscle group might be quite a
bit lower than that or it might be
considerably higher than that so you
look at averages to kind of start the
troubleshooting process uh but
don't
don't don't be disturbed
if your own
experimentation
leads you to something that is
uh kind of kind of far from the average
because there there is a lot of
variability in terms of volume tolerance
between individuals
all right good stuff uh we're at an hour
and five minutes i'm very proud of us
for for getting through the episode and
hell yeah staying close to the hour mark
so
to play us out um in our last episode we
kind of vaguely mentioned that one of
the big things in the online nutrition
space these days
is a lot of um
a lot of bad press related to seed oils
a lot of people suggesting that they are
are quite deleterious and quite
unhealthy in the human diet we mentioned
that we weren't really tapped into that
uh conversation too much like we we kind
of speculated what that might be about
what the basis for those concerns might
be
uh a
a couple listeners sent me some articles
about uh
what's going on in the world where
people are really concerned about seed
oils
and it was pretty much what we were kind
of assuming a lot of the a lot of the
stuff came from um websites that trended
in the
paleo to keto to carnivore kind of theme
and so a lot of the general concerns
were
you know these seed oils have a lot of
uh unsaturated bonds in the fatty acid
chain and those are prone to oxidation
and so theoretically
you consume a lot of these seed oils
there's going to be all of this
oxidation going on of these unsaturated
fatty acid bonds and that's going to
have implications for overall
inflammation and for the development of
atherosclerotic plaques and things like
that so that was kind of one genre of
concern another genre was just that seed
oils have gone up over the last x number
of decades and
they correlate with a lot of bad things
in terms of health outcomes but
anything that changed over the last 80
years is going to positively or
negatively correlate with bad stuff just
based on which direction it it went you
know i mean like
generally speaking health outcomes for a
number of cardiometabolic diseases have
gotten worse um you know if you go back
the last hundred years or so not in a
perfectly linear relationship or
anything like that but
you see these arguments all the time
where people take a snapshot of the time
frame where heart disease went up and
they say well the thing i don't like
also went up during that time frame
seems bad
so that was another genre
but
generally speaking you know i looked
into some of them it's a lot of concern
but not a lot of
uh
actual evidence of human beings
eating an otherwise healthy diet that
incorporates seed oils and then
experiencing any clear deleterious
outcomes and so
i i personally i mean anyone listening
to the show has probably picked up on
this anyone who follows our written work
i don't get a big buzz out of debunking
stuff
and like getting a really deep like once
i assess the argument and say okay
there's really not much here
i'm comfortable just kind of leaving it
at that saying uh here's kind of
some better evidence to go with i don't
lose sleep about people being wrong on
the internet
i can just move past it
but i do understand that you know
there's a lot of people making
convincing arguments about why you
should be worried about seed oils and i
do want to at least put a helpful
resource out there so if you're
listening if you check the show notes
i'm going to link to uh an article
from the nutrafor the
nutrivore.com
it is uh kind of a rebuttal to a lot of
the
common concerns about seed oils
it's long
it estimates that it's a 66 minute read
and it's got like 200 references
but it goes through in a very
comprehensive way most of the scary
claims about seed oils and then present
some pretty strong evidence to uh
alleviate those concerns pretty much
across the board so
i don't want to
discount the fact that like absolutely
there are people on the internet making
arguments against seed oils that do seem
on the surface to be pretty compelling
uh but if you dig into the research uh a
lot of those arguments get less and less
and less compelling as you move away
from animal model and move toward human
beings who eat food so uh that's good
news for anyone who's had some kind of
lingering concerns about seed oil so
like i said that link will be in the
show notes and i think that does it for
this episode uh as always we really
appreciate everyone for listening and we
will be back with another episode in one
week
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you